Tu as commencé ta recherche.
Après avoir trouvé ton objet d'étude, tu
as posé une question de départ qui t'a permis
de filtrer tes lectures et de trouver des
éléments de réponse.
Tu as organisé ces éléments en différentes
problématiques, il te faut maintenant en
choisir une.
Je m'appelle Sylvain Dramaix, je suis enseignant,
professeur en sciences sociales dans le secondaire
en Belgique et dans cette vidéo, je te donne
les clés pour choisir la meilleure problématique
pour ton travail.
Je pense qu'avant de commencer, on peut rappeler
ce qu'est la problématique.
Selon le manuel de recherche en sciences sociales
de Raymond Quivy, Luc Van Campenhoudt et,
pour la 5e édition, Jacques Marquet.
Il s'agit de l'étape 3 de la démarche des
sciences sociales.
Ils définissent la problématique comme "l'approche
ou la perspective théorique adoptée pour
traiter le problème posé par la question
de départ, autrement dit l'angle sous lequel
les phénomènes vont être étudiés".
Et il peut y avoir plusieurs problématiques
envisageables, ça tu l'auras sans doute remarqué
lors de tes lectures.
Il faut donc bien choisir.
Ce choix est d'autant plus important que la
qualité générale de ton travail dépendra
en grande partie de la pertinence de cette
problématique.
Mais comment faire?
Je vais donc maintenant te proposer 7 types
de problématiques qui peuvent se révéler
être très intéressants pour une recherche
et donc de bons choix.
Pour cela, je me base sur l'article d'André
Gosselin intitulé La notion de problématique
en sciences sociales.
Tu trouveras évidemment toutes les références
dans la description de la vidéo.
Et à la fin de celle-ci, je te dirai le type
de problématique le plus courant dans les
différentes sciences scoiales.
Si ce n'est pas encore fait, je t'invite à
t'abonner et à liker cette vidéo, cela fait
toujours plaisir et c'est en quelque sorte
mon salaire.
L'absence de connaissances sur un objet
Lors de l'exploration, tu as remarqué que
parmi les différents travaux portant sur
un phénomène, un type d'explication était
manquant et qu'il n'y avait pas forcément
beaucoup d'informations sur cette problématique.
Par exemple, je me souviens avoir cherché
il y a quelques années des données sur le
lien entre la détection de la dyslexie et
l'origine sociale.
J'avais été surpris de ne pas trouver grand
chose sur la question.
Et bien, cela constituerait très certainement
une excellente problématique de recherche
car l'absence ou la rareté de connaissances
sur un objet augmente l'intérêt d'une recherche.
Mais quand on débute en sciences sociales,
c'est peut-être compliqué de se lancer sur
cette piste car par définition, il y aura
peu d'informations à trouver.
Et ce n'est pas toujours évident de dénicher
ce genre de perspective étant donné la multitude
de connaissances nouvelles qui émergent chaque
année.
Sais-tu que tous les huits ans, la masse de
travaux scientifiques double?
Pas facile donc de dégoter des thèmes inexplorés.
L'absence d'un point de vue nouveau et différent
Certains phénomènes sociaux ont été tellement
travaillés qu'on ne peut presque plus rien
y apporter de nouveau.
Mais parfois, une nouvelle approche permet
de renouveler complètement une thématique.
Récemment, j'ai lu un article sur la mobilité
sociale qui est un thème très travaillé
en sociologie.
D'ailleurs si tu tapes "mobilité sociale"
dans le moteur de recherche, tu obtiens plus
de 118 millions de résultats!
Dans l'article en question, l'auteur Cyril
Jayet aborde la mobilité sociale de manière
tout à fait nouvelle en utilisant les professions
et non plus les grandes catégories socioprofessionnelles
comme employés, ouvriers, cadres supérieures,
etc.
Et ce nouveau degré de précision dans l'analyse
suffit pour créer une approche originale
et intéressante.
La difficulté avec ce type de problématique
est que tu vas trouver beaucoup beaucoup d'informations
et ce sera très compliqué pour bien sélectionner
tes lectures car il y a surabondance de travaux.
En plus, c'est un challenge que d'être en
mesure d'apporter un regard original surtout
si tu es novice.
La contradiction entre deux explications
Suite à tes lectures, tu peux aussi constater
qu'il existe des explications différentes
d'un même phénomène et que ces explications
sont à la limite contradictoires.
Le cas d'école est la confrontation des thèses
de Bourdieu et de Boudon quant aux inégalités
scolaires.
Qui a raison d'un point de vue empirique?
Je pense que l'on peut élargir ce type de
problématique à d'autres genres d'opposition
par exemple entre une théorie et les faits.
Je me souviens du TFE d'une élève qui avait
construit une problématique particulièrement
intéressante.
On avait étudié en classe La Reproduction
de Pierre Bourdieu qui en gros explique que
l'origine sociale conditionne fortement la
scolarité d'un élève.
A partir de ces leçons, elle avait mis en
tension la théorie de Bourdieu et des statistiques
qui montrent que les trajectoires scolaires
peuvent être différentes pour des frères
et des sœurs.
Ben oui, on connait tous des enfants issus
d'une même fratrie qui n'ont pas les mêmes
résultats à l'école et qui d'ailleurs n'empruntent
pas les mêmes orientations.
Les faits donnent-ils tort à Bourdieu?
C'était l'objet de son travail.
Dans le même ordre d'idée, toute situation
traversée par un axe de tension peut se révéler
être une problématique intéressante.
Le passage de la description à l'explication
Parfois, on connaît l'existence d'un phénomène
mais on ne peut l'expliquer.
Le phénomène est connu, bien décrit, documenté
mais jamais réellement expliqué.
C'est une bonne problématique.
C'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a fait Durkheim avec
son enquête sur Le Suicide.
A l'époque, on disposait de beaucoup de statistiques
sur les taux de suicide des différentes catégories
sociales et de différentes régions.
Mais personne n'était en mesure d'expliquer
les variations de ces chiffres.
Pareil pour Weber, avant ses travaux, on savait
que les capitalistes étaient plus souvent
protestants que catholiques mais on ne savait
pas pourquoi.
Donc à chaque fois que l'on est confronté
à un traitement descriptif d'un phénomène,
apporter une explication c'est-à-dire répondre
à la question "pourquoi" est toujours une
démarche pertinente et une bonne problématique.
L'existence d'un problème théorique
Les 4 premiers types de problématiques sont
surtout des problèmes empiriques.
Mais il peut également être envisageable
d'adopter une problématique plus théorique.
L'intérêt de certains travaux réside surtout
dans la construction d'un modèle d'analyse
cohérent et solide.
On peut par exemple tenter d'améliorer la
cohérence et les liens entre les hypothèses
ou clarifier les concepts utilisés et correctement
les définir.
Ce travail de construction ou de reconstruction
théorique est aussi très judicieux mais
il me semble que c'est une tâche très lourde
pour un élève et cela doit donc rester un
genre de problématique réservé aux chercheurs
plus aguerris.
Mais ce n'est que mon avis.
La résolution d'un problème méthodologique
ou épistémologique
Certaines études comportent des biais ou
des erreurs de méthode qui peuvent être
discutées voire résolues dans un nouveau
travail.
D'ailleurs, certains chercheurs indiquent
parfois dans leurs conclusions ce qui aurait
pu être fait autrement d'un point de vue
méthodologique.
On pense par exemple à des choix de méthodes
d'observation, d'échantillonnage, à des
limites conjoncturelles comme la crise sanitaire
qui empêchent la bonne tenue de l'observation
et donc d'avoir des résultats de recherche
pleinement satisfaisants.
D'ailleurs, des études ultérieures aux travaux
de Durkheim sur le suicide ont eu comme unique
problématique de rediscuter des erreurs méthdologiques
de l'oeuvre alors qu'il s'agit d'un monument
de la sociologie.
Le besoin d'une réponse pratique
Les collectivités humaines doivent parfois
trouver des solutions à des problèmes concrets.
Les sciences sociales peuvent proposer des
pistes d'action sur base des nouvelles connaissances
dégagées par une recherche.
Il se peut donc que tu choisisses une problématique
qui entend contribuer à trouver une solution
non plus empirique ou théorique mais bien
pratique.
Ici l'enjeu est de savoir quoi faire et comment
faire face à une situation déterminée.
Par exemple, une recherche peut s'intéresser
aux manières de minimiser la phobie scolaire
afin que les écoles puissent lutter efficacement
contre ce phénomène qui menace la bonne
scolarité de certains élèves.
A titre personnel, je trouve qu'il faut faire
attention avec ce genre de problématique
car on arrive très vite dans une approche
normative où le mélange des genre est une
menace et pour des élèves qui s'initient
aux sciences sociales, cela peut être compliqué
à gérer ce qui n'est bien sûr pas le cas
pour les chercheurs plus expérimentés.
Tu connais donc maintenant les différents
types de problématiques envisageables pour
ta recherche.
Tu dois bien avoir conscience qu'il ne s'agit
ici que de modèles pour te donner des idées
et que dans la réalité des formes hybrides
ou nouvelles sont possibles.
Dans l'article à la base de cette vidéo,
l'auteur, André Gosselin donne les résultats
de l'observation qu'il a réalisée sur base
de 587 articles de sciences humaines et sociales.
Que cela soit en sociologie, en sciences politiques,
en communication ou en économie, l'absence
de point de vue nouveau est le type de problématique
le plus souvent privilégié.
Je te mets bien sûr le lien de l'article
ci-dessous afin que tu puisses tout consulter
en détail et à ton aise.
Malheureusement cette étude date de 1994,
une réactualisation de ses résultats serait
sans aucun doute une excellente problématique
de recherche.
A très bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo,